place au bilan de cette année politique
alors un ex président avait coutume de
dire qu'en histoire rien ne se passe
jamais comme prévu ben on en a encore eu
la preuve avec cette folle séquence
électorale on aura vu des victoire en
trompe-l'oeil des perdants qui se
prennent pour des gagnants des soufflets
qui monte qui retombe bref on aura tout
vu retour sur une année politique à
nulle autre pareille avec jonathan du
prix y est zemmour futur président
l'hypothèse n'a pas manqué de dynamiter
le début de campagne présidentielle
qu'un politique donnée entre 15 et 17%
des voix au premier tour le polémiste
d'extrême droite se voyait déjà à
l'elysée sans portée par une
hypothétique l'union des droites
derrière son projet si je gagne cette
élection ce ne sera pas une alternance
de plus mais le début de la reconquête
du plus beau pays du monde
mais sa campagne émaillée de polémiques
s'enraye al'inverse sa concurrente
directe marine le pen sillonne la france
à bas bruit sur le thème du pouvoir
d'achat grignotant peu à peu l'espace
politique est mort et 1 25% sur le
quinquennat pour les
personnes véritablement à paris fin
février la guerre en ukraine change la
dynamique de l'élection emmanuel macron
retard de son entrée en campagne reste
en surplomb porté par les aidera main et
l'occident unis started a exposé son
programme de mesures seront
particulièrement critiqué la réforme des
retraites et celle du rsa
parallèlement jean luc mélenchon
progresse dans les sondages on se posant
comme candidat du vote utile à gauche
avec l'affaiblissement d'eric zemmour
marine le pen progresse elle aussi sans
pâtir de ses accointances avec moscou le
premier tour s'annonce serré mais
emmanuel macron s'impose avec un score
plus élevé qu'attendu 28% la droite est
sèchement désavoué valérie pécresse
échoue sous la barre des 5% c'est un
échec historique et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne je veux très en
confiance emmanuel macron pour empêcher
l'arrivée au pouvoir de marine le pen et
le chaos qui en résulterait au terme
d'un entre-deux tours sans ferveur
emmanuel macron bas marine le pen et
rempile pour cinq ans à peine l'élection
terminée les regards se tournent vers la
bataille des législatives
jean luc mélenchon réussit le tour de
force d' unir la gauche et les
écologistes sous la bannière nuque
malgré une campagne poussive l'extrême
droite fait une percée historique en
envoyant 89 députés au palais bourbon la
nuque avec 143 sièges devient
mécaniquement la première force
d'opposition à emmanuel macron les
maquereaux nist quant à eux essuie un
sérieux revers renaissance devra
composer avec une majorité relative
obligeant la première ministre à des
compromis nous mènerons pour chaque
sujet une concertation danse nous
aborderons chaque texte dans un esprit
de dialogue et de compromis et
d'ouverture les cinq prochaines années
de réforme s'annonce donc délicate pour
emmanuel macron en témoignent les
récents débats houleux à l'assemblée
nationale sur les projets de loi qu vide
ou sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors ce bilan de l'année on va le
dresser avec nos experts ce soir sa
verrière ogec bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste vous venez de publier
résurrection les coulisses d'une
reconquête chez stock une reconquête
s'était pas celle d'eric zemmour pour le
coup
des manuels meymac rouge accueille
également nicolas prissette journaliste
et fondateur du média fondamentale point
fr et puis à vos côtés jean sébastien
ferjou fondateur et directeur
d'atlantico à l'habitude ce plateau et
puis dans le rôle de chroniqueuse
politique emilie s'appelle squeeze qui
m'accompagnera évidemment tout au long
de l'émission alors je voulais vous
commencé quand même en vous posant une
petite série de questions qui vont
rythmer ce débat
avec la première qui est le ou la grande
gagnante de cette séquence politique qui
veut quand c'est
sans surprise je pense pas qu'on puisse
dire car notre grand gagnant qu emmanuel
macron parce qu'il a néanmoins malgré
tout ce qu'on peut dire il a néanmoins
réussi ce tour de force de se faire
élire pour la première fois hors
périodes de cohabitation pour un second
mandat présidentiel
il faut se rappeler c'est à dire aussi
l'objet de mon livre de l'enquète que je
mène ses il faut se rappeler la haine
qu'ils suscitaient à l'époque de gilet
jaune je pense qu'aucun autre président
sous la vème république n'a été à eacom
il a été à lille oui les désistements
plus oui mais une rappelons-nous
effectivement les manifestations avec sa
tête au bout d'une pique il y avait une
violence j'ai trouvé sur sa personne sur
son épouse qui était pas ce nicolas
sarkozy s'était plus sa personnalité fin
c'était autre chose en tout cas est
comment voilà emmanuel macron réussi ce
tour de force alors peut-être que les
circonstances il explique notamment la
grande crâne on va peut-être en parler
mais je trouve qu'ils dressent le grand
gagnant fin qui fait mieux que gagner
une élection présidentielle cette année
est néanmoins malgré tout ce qu'on peut
dire également une élection législative
nicolas oui alors je suis pas du tout
d'accord je pense que je les mets dans
la catégorie
non j'aime emmanuel macron plutôt dans
dans la catégorie des des perdants mais
pourrait revenir mais pour moi la
gagnante c'est une femme c'est marine le
pen parce qu'elle est elle à une seconde
enfin une présidentielle où elle arrive
au second tour
certes elle sait qu'elle va perdre mais
elles en tirent des bénéfices nouveau en
termes de notabilisation et puis elle a
group inespéré à l'assemblée nationale
elle a progressé partout c'est le seul
parti politique le rassemblement
national qui peut présenter autant de
gains et y compris être élu désormais en
duel aux législatives face à des des
candidats de la majorité notamment alors
que par le passé le front national et
avait des députés uniquement dans des
triangulaires dans des circonstances
parfois particulièrement discutable mais
aujourd'hui les un parti qui est en
train de progresser qui a des nouvelles
bases qui a une force politique et
internationale qu'il compte en capacité
de faire ou de défaire des majorités à
sur des textes sur des articles on l'a
vu cette semaine et donc pour moi c'est
marine le pen qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un jeu de pâques ça va être
comme ça pendant tout quinquennat mais
en tout cas qui aujourd'hui est dans une
situation sort plutôt dans une position
de force et la part emporté à wim est
dans une position de force qui était
inespéré pour elle ni moi j'ai
complètement d'accord avec nicolas je
pense que vraiment marine le pen a gagné
le pouvoir d'achat le fait de s'être mis
sur cette thématique du pouvoir d'achat
avant les autres et d'une manière très
rentable puisque la garonne nous a remis
une couche là dessus après le qu'ovide
je pense qu'elle a fortement gagné 89
députés et rennes il va falloir voir
comment il se professionnalise ça ça va
être un petit peu l'enjeu mais c'est une
force incroyable il va falloir aussi
voir comment il joue l'opposition entre
constructif raisonnable et quand même
garder cette espèce de caractère un
petit peu à rebrousse poil ça va être un
peu l'enjeu de demain moi je pense que
ce qui a véritablement changé c'est
qu'on parle plus d'extrême droite on
n'arrive plus à parler d'extrême droite
ça ne revient plus du trait dessus et ça
c'est quelque chose qui a énormément
évolué cette année c'est vraiment le
bout du bout du bout de la normalisation
de l'institutionnalisation la
notabilisation je crois que là il est au
summum gens se massent à faire jouer
je suis à la fois de l'accord est pas
d'accord non mais je trouve qu'il ya
surtout des faiblesses qui se regardent
en chiens de faïence et que chacun est
sur des faiblesses alors oui madame
macro incontestablement a regagné
l'élection présidentielle et personne ne
peut contester ce résultat là ni
effectivement le côté à la fois sans
précédent et palais d'un concile a de
nouveau échoué mais la preuve le marine
le pen a de nouveau échoué effectivement
à la présidentielle maintenant là où je
trouve que ce sont surtout des
faiblesses qui se regardent en chiens de
faïence et que à chaque fois ce sont des
gagnants par défaut c'est parce qu'ils
ne sont pas les autres regardent et
marine le pen elle gagne enfin viennent
pas mais comme le disait nicolas
prissette un résultat inespéré pour le
groupe rassemblement national alors
qu'elle fait pas véritablement campagne
pour les législatives principalement
parce qu'elle n'est pas les deux autres
ou en tout cas que les candidats et
rennes ne sont ni des candidats soutenus
par les mêmes macron ni les candidats de
lannux et donc on est dans cet espace de
faïza donc pour moi le gagnant ça serait
peut-être plus tôt une institution le
parlement parce que le contexte
politique actuel non mais c'est une
bonne chose en matière de démocratie
parce que ça fait bien longtemps qu'on a
oublié la séparation d avec on a oublié
l'équilibré des pouvoirs fille de redire
montesquieu pour pour le savoir et
j'espère parce que nous sommes
uniquement dans le potentiel en l'état
mais j'espère que ça permettra de
revitaliser la démocratie française ce
qu'il faut aussi dans les gagnants
d'hier sans doute un mot de jean luc
mélenchon qui reste un des grands
gagnants de l'année même si il n'a pas
paradoxalement été élu puisqu'il ne
s'est pas présenté mais néanmoins il
réussit ce tour de force votre reportage
montrait bien d'unir autour de lui
gauche c'est bien une gauche radicale du
gauche clivante mais c'est une gauche
qui respire encore ce qui n'était pas
gagné il ya quelques mois on y reviendra
aussi l'année où juste leur
rapidement maintenant perdant une grande
perdante oui je l'évoqué mêmes
incompétents bon pour moi c'est emmanuel
macron parce qu'on on a un président
fait
donc voilà attendez l'argument
on a un président a répliqué réélu c'est
exceptionnel et qui est quand même
capable de perdre les législatives d'y
perdre parce qu'il a perdu la main et
aujourd'hui pour faire passer ses
réformes et l'objet de négocier article
par article avec des gens qui sont tous
contre lui il n'est plus à le le chef de
l'état et du gouvernement et de la
majorité capable de faire tout ce qu'il
veut pendant ce quinquennat maintenant
il est lié il a son destin lié avec ce
que vont bien vouloir lui concéder des
oppositions qui se projette déjà dans
cinq ans alors que lui il sera plus là
donc
circonstances politiques qui est assez
exceptionnel il ya déjà eu des majorité
relative des
soûlards les salles et ben l'oncle soul
a sous la vème république ah mais
d'avoir un président de la république
est réélu avec là on l'a entendu long
reportage un score supérieur à celui de
2010 est et qui est en incapacité de
pouvoir mener sa politique c'est quand
même voilà une circonstance avec eux on
s'attendait plan quand ils partent pas
du cnes et qui s'appelait écuyers et qui
en situation de faiblesse ils vont y va
découvrir la culture du compromis entre
pardon mais entre le projet d' emmanuel
macron présenter aux français à
l'élection présidentielle de cette année
et ce qui va être mis en oeuvre par la
voie législative jusqu'à
sur ce qu'il peut faire ou non
sa dernière interview qu'ils allaient
faire leur retraite ferr l'assurance à
70 ans attendait
l'immense perdant à mon sens reste eric
zemmour il ya encore six mois nous tous
observateurs politiques ont regardé ce
phénomène qui avait plus rond quelques
semaines et qui était à quasiment 15%
tout le monde s'attendait à ce qu'ils
soient au second tour qui lexique lips
complètement marine le pen et six mois
plus tard là c'est aussi la magie de la
politique c'est de voir à quel point
phénomène gonfle et puis c'est des
groupes aussi vite c'est évidemment il a
été élu il n'a pas été présent au second
tour il n'a même pas un seul député ça
aussi qui est intéressant c'est parce
que dans le voir lui même battu mais
parce que reconquête son parti a eu des
adhésions enfin voilà financement
c'était ont pensé qu'au moins il y
aurait une sorte de rattrapage aux
élections législatives et même là ça n'a
pas fonctionné jean sébastien giray le
cercle de la raison ce qu'on a un club
du cercle de la raison depuis vous aimez
derrière et se blaise emmanuel macron il
ya savoir si ce que c'est pour nos
téléspectateurs ses effets politiques
possibles en voilà et une seule
politique possible c'est un peu ce qui
s'est mis en place à partir de 1983 avec
la politique du franc fort et ce dont je
parle ce n'est pas cette politique là en
particulier mais c'est la manière dont
ça s'est décalé dans le temps et d'envié
une espèce d'asphyxié intellectuelle on
a mis le système français les élites
technocratiques
françaises ont finalement enfin une
techno politiques français ont mis à
l'écart tous les gens qui parfois oser
penser différemment alors de jean pierre
chevènement à philippe seguin ou à
d'autres et on voit bien les regarder ce
qui est en train de se passer a dit
adieu à l'heure actuelle c'est la même
chose c'est tout un logiciel
intellectuelle qui est finalement celui
qui constitue notre monde et qui a sans
trop le vouloir totalement d'ailleurs
mis en place cette espèce de
mondialisation à la fois enfin le
capitalisme est très mondialisé et très
financiarisé et en disant il n'y a pas
d'autre choix pas d'autre voie que celle
là dans nos engagements européens dans
nos engagements énergétiques sauf que le
temps a passé et que justement on se
rend compte que beaucoup des décisions
qui étaient présentés comme raisonnables
les tous les autres étant décrit comme
démagogue incompétent d'ailleurs c'est
encore l'argument qu'employé vous à
l'essentiel alternat des manades face à
marine le pen en dix ans elle est à la
fois dangereuse pour la république est
incompétente le problème c'est que ça
n'est pas parce que le cercle de la
raison a fait la preuve en quelque sorte
d'une part de son incompétence à rend
pas les autres compétent pour autant
mais quoi qu'il en soit ce recul là et 7
ils sont au pied du mur et pour que le
système s'en sortent il va bien falloir
qu'il accepte de revisiter cette
histoire des trente quarante dernières
années mais on peut décliner surtout sur
l'autorité de l'état ce de faim sur
l'éducation sur nous sommes un vrai
moment où la déconstruction a fini par
produire ses effets et où il va falloir
reconstruire et bien moi je suis assez
david eric zemmour et c'est d'ailleurs
rassurant parce que cette espèce de mono
maniaque itude sur le grand remplacement
messin pas fait long feu ça fait
beaucoup d'effet quand il était parti là
quand il n'était pas candidat il a
beaucoup augmenté sa notoriété et son
spectre médiatique quand il n'était pas
candidat ça fait un flop quand il a
fallu parler d'économie il fait 7 %
parmi
les candidats traditionnels de partis
traditionnels il a fait mais il a fait
sur un effet temps assez réduit et les
plus rien on pourrait parler aussi de
valérie pécresse ans aussi parce qu'elle
n'a pas trouvé sa ligne à la patrouille
et son ton et les as l'air n'ont
globalement pas trouvé de figure pour
être représentés ça a été quand même un
beau flop éciation charitables
sur eric zemmour je pense que c'est un
échec pour l'hexagone incontestablement
y compris d'ailleurs pour un certain
nombre de gens qui sont engagés à ses
côtés mais c'est aussi une forme d'échec
des médias je crois qu'il ya deux
démocraties qui vivent en parallèle il
ya une démocratie médiatique des
sondages de l'opinion des polémiques sur
des plateaux de chaînes d'info à fond le
tout venant pendant le quinquennat puis
à la démocratie institutionnelle avec
les élections et notamment l'élection
présidentielle une fois tous les cinq
ans et les deux ne se superposent que
très imparfaitement sauf que souvent
quand on fait l'analyse politique on a
le nez collé uniquement sur la
démocratie médiatique sans se rendre
compte que les électeurs ils sont très
loin de ça et que parfois justement il
ya des effet d'emballement médiatique
qui ne correspondent pas tout à fait à
soigner des savanes emballement
médiatique alors j'ai pris beaucoup de
temps mais juste des arts y avaient péri
de bulles détruites sans que ce soit un
grand perdant est ce qu'un lapin car
raté le coche c'est yannick jadot au
fond c'est que tout le monde parle de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
je la primaire des écolos c'était pas si
mal passé que ça je me suis posé la
question de le mettre dans les perdants
jusqu'à ce que je réalise qu'il avait
fait nettement mieux que valérie
pécresse mieux que yannick dago ce qui
n'est pas pour ça que j'ai sans en faire
un grand perdant mais
voilà ils ont eu l'initiative était pas
si mauvais également certes aujourd'hui
non mais vous avez raison il ya quelque
chose de il a raté le coche comme ou
lite effectivement il aurait pu il
aurait pu prendre la tête incarner cette
gauche sociale démocrate écologiste
ya eu ils sont battus avec endel go et
finalement ni dernier notons ont réussi
le candidat de la raison un peu comme
vous dites jean-sébastien reste à est
resté emmanuel macron pour ces derniers
ce qui d'ailleurs panique jadot et aux
écologistes ils ont du mal à se
positionner dans cette nouvelle nuxe on
les voit pas vraiment on y voit pas
émerger comme une fausse avantage de
voix ils ont julien bayou a beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à se positionner dans
cette force politique et c'est davantage
un sujet europe ecologie les verts jeu
que de yanick jean
ce
que yannick jadot justement c'est pas
julien bayou il ya yannick jadot a tenté
d'incarner une ligne pour le coût
raisonnable là je le dis déjà parlé de
manière péjorative concernant sert de la
raison je n'y mets pas de connotation
péjorative en ce qui concerne sauf que
ça n'a pas marché du tout et c'est tout
l'échec de cette gauche mais on voit
bien qu'il ya une impossibilité face à
ce défi climatique de trouver la
stratégie politique qui marche la
stratégie de l'anticapitalisme de la
décroissance et du catastrophisme elle
ne marche pas les stratégies à la greta
tanberg ça ne marche pas ça ne marche
dans aucune démocratie occidentale sauf
que les mêmes continuent à essayer de
mettre de déployer là même la même
stratégie lui à essayer autre chose il a
échoué justement dans cet autre chose
mais au moins d'intention était lourd
sur jeunes alors parce qu'il parle
d'investissements et de taxi mais c'est
le dixième l'intention était louable à
morcenx on va parler d'étiquettes ou de
sensibilité un peu désormais pas
seulement de personnalités on y
reviendra avec une petite phrase qu'on a
beaucoup lu cette année
c'est que la france n'a jamais été aussi
à droite c'est vrai nicolas brossette
alors c'est vrai si on regarde les
déclarations des français quand ils sont
interrogés pour se positionner sur un
axe droit de gauche et c'est vrai qu'il
ya un déport à droite qu'on voit de plus
en plus accentuée au fil des années là
je fais référence aux enquêtes du
cevipof qui sont assez précise sur ce
point là ça c'est à dire le la demande
mais après côté de l'offre politique il
ya aussi on vient d'évoquer une
faiblesse de la gauche qui fait que la
droite focalise focalise toute
l'attention et le le coup de jean luc
mélenchon d'arriver à fédérer cette
gauche et à lui donner davantage
d'allant et davantage de daisy des
réhabiliter je peux le dire pour ses
électeurs a montré que bon même s'il y
avait de la part des français une
demande de droite en tout cas un
positionnement à droite qui a été
majoritaire il ya une gauche qui existe
toujours et qui reste assez forte avec
une demande d'identité demande d'
identité de gauche qui est
particulièrement prononcée alors après
total gauche sur les gia d'illégal
inférieur à celui de 1993 les rockets et
la demande des tic est de gauche si on
peut dire comme ça la demande des tic
est de gauche elle reste très fort très
vivace après le contenu bon les gens par
était trop regardants vous savez
le comment dire on ne peut pas déduire
que
les valeurs de la gauche serait
minoritaire dans l'opinion par exemple
et avec qui on met à droite aujourd'hui
qui vous mettez à droite vous ça
commence à partie des magnolias
vaqueront j'ai envie de dire qu'ils que
je classerais plutôt au centre droit et
pour vous répondre à des questions sur
qui sont effectivement est ce que la
france est le plus à droite force est de
constater que les deux candidats
emmanuel macron marine le pen sont
arrivés en au second tour l'élection
présidentielle sont des candidats de
droite alors emmanuel macron certes de
centre droit d'être une droite très
modérée et marine le pen une droite
qu'on appelle plus extrêmes mais qui
reste de l'extrême droite ou une droite
nationale ou radical voilà à définir ce
qui me semble intéressant c'est que ces
candidats autoproclamés de droite font
aujourd'hui campagne est encore
aujourd'hui sur des thèmes j'allais dire
de gauche c'est à dire le pouvoir dans
le on soutient le pouvoir d'achat rond
soutien des services publics c'est une
plus forte demande de services publics
que ce soit marine le pen vous l'avez
rappelé et minet qui a fait toute sa
campagne sur effectivement le pouvoir
d'achat des français que ce soit
aujourd'hui même emmanuel macron qui
encore hier 10 ce qui nous sauve
effectivement des catastrophes
climatiques et bien c'est l'état ont
fait on va racheter plus d'appareils
pour combattre protecteur
et économiques dans cette droite
autoproclamée dans les échecs et
classique de connaissons tous qui
néanmoins défend aujourd'hui des thèmes
qui sont des thèmes mais ça je pensais
la pandémie qui a tout changé c'est quoi
qu'il en coûte qui est changé cette
demande effectivement très forte de
service public que des candidats
autoproclamés de droite ne se cache plus
de défendre jean-sébastien on en parlait
tout à l'heure pour la première fois
l'extrême droite a dépassé la barre des
30% au premier tour si on additionne
marine le pen eric zemmour et nicolas
dupont aignan on a rappelé mme on peut
le rappeler le score de marine le pen au
second tour c'est surtout en nombre de
voix de choc c'est important 13 3
millions deux voix et pour la première
fois on l'a dit aussi enfin l'extrême
droite qui fait une entrée en force au
parlement on pose la question à l'heure
est ce qu'on peut encore parler d'
extrêmement pauvre qu'est ce qu'on met
dans l'extrême droite tout dépend si on
regarde les électeurs ou si on regarde
les différents représentants les
différents élus des partis il y à arn en
héritage une filiation idéologique qui
sont incontestablement lié à l'extrême
droite que vous avez senti dans la
campagne
non parce que je trouve qu'on enfin la
chasse aux fascistes et totalement
grotesque puisqu'il n'y a pas dans la
vie politique commune il ya des gens qui
peuvent être sur les marges de la vie
politique française on les a vus dans
certains meetings avec peut-être des
ménages qui n'avait pas été suffisamment
fait dans la campagne d'eric zemmour
notamment ça peut exister mais ça reste
très marginal je ne crois pas que ça
existe dans l'électorat il n'y a pas de
demande d'extrême droite au sens de
retour à ce qui serait un régime très
autoritaire et un régime qui
installerait une espèce de ségrégation
entre les citoyens à raison de
caractéristiques religieuse et donc ou
autre de ce point de vue là non je ne
crois pas qu'ils aient encore d'extrême
droite il ya quelque chose qui ressemble
plus à une espèce de droite populiste
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on met derrière
les mots parce qu'on dit que
manuellement un peu enfin je suis
d'accord à me battre là dessus et on
peut dire qu'elle mène ma chronique
centre droit que marine le pen est
droite mais c'est quoi la droite à mon
sens la droite c'est quand même en
général préférait la liberté à l'égalité
je ne suis pas sûr que ça qualifie ni
l'un ni l'autre chez mama c'est certain
de l' inverse parce que je n'aime macron
pendant dans la gestion d'actions delhi
la liberté non non emmanuel macron et au
contraire celui qui a le plus piétiner
jeu pendant l'histoire de la république
la culture des libertés publiques en ne
faisant d'ailleurs aucune
proportionnalité entre les restrictions
aux libertés publiques et l'efficacité
qu'on pouvait en attendre quant à
emmanuel macron sur l'économie il n'est
pas du tout libéral ayman
c'est long mais c'est le pur produit
dont je parlais de ce que je vous ai je
vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est cette
matrice intellectuelle des élites
françaises qui considère que des toits
doit finalement doit tout gérer avec en
plus l'aspect narcissique c'est à dire
que quand on considère qu en plus l'état
c'est moi vous voyez on est quand même
assez loin de ce qu'on pourrait
ressembler un environnement libéral
après marine le pen et n'est pas
libérale non tu n es pas
fondamentalement conservait triste ont
pu se dire que les deux piliers qui font
tous les grands partis de droite de
gouvernement dans la plupart des
démocraties occidentales
le libéralisme et le conservatisme quand
on dit ça c'est pas libéralisme vouloir
tout goldman sachs ise ni le
conservatisme au sens des retours en
arrière toute non quelque chose qui
considèrent qu'ils aient des héritages à
préserver d'une part et que on préfère
malgré tout la liberté économique au
fait que l'état est ainsi s'occupe de
tout
bizarrement elle me venir ni l'hôtel ni
sécuritaire on va parler de l'adjointe
français j'aimerais parler des
républicains parce que les républicains
il avait un peu fondu comme neige au
soleil et puis ont l'impression qu'ils
reprennent du poil de la bête depuis ces
derniers jours on va en parler avec
style jourdain ouï mais annonce-t-il ils
ont pris du poil de la bête les fidjiens
j'ai été je pourrai dire à mes enfants
et petits-enfants que j étais ce soir ce
fameux soir de défaite pour valérie
pécresse dimanche 10 avril maison de la
chimie à paris vous en rappelez sans
doute c'était un sport de revers
historique pour le grand parti gaulliste
-2 5% à l'élection suprême tout
simplement du jamais vu les barons de la
droite parlait alors de claques
d'humiliation de mort du parti faut dire
que c'était la troisième défaite de rang
après 2012 et 2017 et tout le monde à
droite voyaient venir les élections
législatives du mois de juin avec
crainte résultat ça valait leur sauve
quand même les meubles certes ils
étaient plus de 100 avant les élections
mais ils ont quand même sauvé 62 sièges
à l'assemblée nationale après l'annonce
des résultats christian jacob pouvait
montrer les muscles écouter leurs
du quinquennat par emmanuel macron le
fait qu'il a instrumentalisé les
extrêmes on l'a vu
à l'élection présidentielle il a
continué avec les élections législatives
et s'amène ce résultat est encore une
fois la balle est dans son est dans son
camp aujourd'hui mais pour nous il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté
nous sommes dans une opposition
déterminée à emmanuel macron une
opposition déterminée des activistes en
jacob qui depuis on le sait après lui
chantait s'il n'est plus à la tête du
mouvement elle est devenue bienveillante
plutôt non cette opposition de plus ces
derniers jours et surtout surtout pas
dire ça aux élus et l'air est pourtant
effectivement mathieu avec l'examen des
premiers textes au parlement on voit le
rôle central qui est en train de jouer
le parti a l'air dans la fabrique de la
loi enrôlent de force d'appoint aux
côtés de la majorité relative des
manuels macro avec évidemment des
exigences sur des points clés des
projets de loi tenait prenons par
exemple le projet de loi sanitaire il a
été adopté par le sénat à majorité de
droite dans la nuit les sénateurs ont
réintroduit un dispositif proche de ce
que souhaitait le gouvernement à
l'origine et qui avait été supprimé par
les députés avec le feu vert du sénat
confirmé en commission mixte paritaire
l'exécutif pourra demander un certificat
sanitaire de voyages aux personnes qui
entrent sur le territoire français en
cas d'apparition de nouveaux variants en
bref le gouvernement voulait rétablir le
passé ni terre à partir de 12 ans le
sénat dit oui mais sous certaines
conditions
il ya quelques nuances en mai la
philosophie n'est pas très éloignées
entre les maquereaux nist et les as
l'air mais surtout surtout mathieu ne
prononcez pas le mot rapprochement de
vendre une eau retailleau philippe bas
ce n'est pas un rapprochement c'est un
bras de fer c'est le résultat d'un bras
de fer depuis toujours le sénat cherche
à apporter quelque chose à la loi et je
vous signale que sous le précédent
quinquennat nous avons abouti à de très
nombreux accords en particulier sur la
lutte contre le coc vide donc c'est
notre travail nous le faisons depuis
longtemps nous continuerons à le faire
nous exprimons dans le vote de la loi
nos propres convictions ensuite nous en
discutons avec nos collègues députés et
si on prend en compte notre point de vue
que nous croyons juste par définition
alors nous signer au bas du parchemin un
accord pour que la loi soit améliorée
prochain rendez vous capital pour les
l'air la désignation d'un nouveau patron
du ciel cet hiver en coulisses ça à
taille sur la ligne a déjà commencé
merci alors même ratatiner ils peuvent
prendre leur revanche les républicains
ça peuvent être les arbitres de ce
quinquennat nicolas précède bien sûr ils
sont aujourd'hui dans une position
exceptionnelle d'avoir pris une claque
monumentale à la présidentielle et et en
même temps d'être capable d'imposer
peut-être à emmanuel macron des des
amendements des modifications à ces
projets parce qu'il a besoin d'eux pour
faire passer les textes et pour que
l'assemblée puisse fonctionner
le temps que ça durera parce qu'il ya un
moment où vraisemblablement l'histoire
sera différente mais bon là ils sont
dans une position exceptionnelle de de
négociation et et d'arbitrage alors ici
au sénat bien sûr c'était déjà le cas
avant mais à l'assemblée nationale je
pense qu'il s'y attendait pas à eux
mêmes après dans les premiers votes
convoi d'aidé des articles sur le projet
doit pouvoir d'achat on voit qu'ils sont
pas tous à l'unisson c'est à dire que
l'ensemble du groupe même vu des
bisbilles entre les sénateurs l'ensemble
du groupe républicain déjà à l'assemblée
même n'a pas tous les députés verts
n'ont pas tous voté en faveur des
premiers d'antibes qui ont été discutées
mais bon ils sont en tout cas en cette
capacité de peser sur le gouvernement et
de faire valoir certains choix et donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui était
absolument inattendu et l'oreille satané
2022 on a vu aussi des choses à gauche
on veut renaître l'union de la gauche ce
vieux rêve ça peut durer saveria rouge
avec
force est de constater que je suis pas
sûr je pense que effectivement on voit
déjà on les a vus se déchirer avant même
que la nuit peut exister réellement on a
vu effectivement les figures c'est un
ancienne figure du parti socialiste
sa star ancien ministre hollandais
certaines figures actuelles comme carl
belga la patronne de la région occitanie
qui était qu'on ne fera pas partie du
peloton qui compte effectivement mais
enfin de cette gauche dont est issue une
partie la nuque on voit que
le ce qu'il en reste du ps d'un levier
fort a rejoint effectivement la nuque
combien de temps on parlait tout à
l'heure des écologistes combien de temps
les écologistes modéré danic shadow ou
vous les socialistes qui reste des
socialistes modérés vont pouvoir tenir
au sein de cette assemblée a chassé
clivant assez radicale que reste la
nuque on les voit depuis quelques jours
dans l'hémicycle ils sont extrêmement
bruyant plutôt radicaux on voit bien
qu'il ne cherche absolument pas le
compromis c'est-à-dire ils ont une
attitude même qui est complètement
opposé au député du rassemblement
des socialistes des écologistes vont
tenir là-dedans je pense pas que ça
tienne effectivement très très longtemps
jean sébastien ferjou grand artisan de
cette union par la force ou ne savent
pas foncer jean luc mélenchon qu'elle a
une troisième homme de la présidentielle
et oui qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent
sans mandat c'est par président il s'est
pas représenté est ce que la france
insoumise peut survivre à son chef ou
sans son chef
oui je probablement
survivre à plus facilement que la nulle
sans compter stablement je pense que
jean luc mélenchon représente un peu une
malédiction comme jean marie le pen sur
jean marie le pen a réussi à faire du fn
quelque chose n'aurait jamais dû être
parce que pour le coup la création du fn
c'était vraiment le rassemblement de
courants d'extrême droite divers
d'ailleurs 13 opposer les uns aux autres
il a porté sa un niveau électoral quasi
inespérée par rapport à ce qui était
produit politique premier mais ça a été
la malédiction aussi serre que c'est
comme dans un jeu car il c'est le fils
qui vous rappellent une fois que vous
êtes parti trop loin et jean luc
mélenchon c'est un peu la même chose
qu'il réussit grâce à une forme de très
grande intelligence politique il réussit
un vrai coup mais en recréant la gauche
en reconstruisant sur un centre de
gravité qui est trop décalé
vraisemblablement par rapport à ce
qu'est l'électorat de gauche et surtout
avec un choix qui portent des choses sur
les sujets sociétaux c'est à dire qu'on
voit bien c'est très inspiré on appelle
ça le bloquiste maintenant et c'est
assez peu reconstruit et assez peu de
propositions véritables sur la question
économique et social et c'est ce qui
affaiblit la gauche comme la droite
plus de discours économique c'est
d'ailleurs une de ces leçons de cette
séquence électorale s'était pas eu
tellement d'idées neuves si vous en avez
vu les non mais regardez même nom dagens
industri rien que le fait de pouvoir
d'achat je vais sa part les mini est
déjà un renoncement intellectuelle parce
que le pouvoir d'achat c'est un résultat
ce n'est pas un objectif en soi
l'objectif c'est la création de richesse
qui permet de garantir le pouvoir
d'achat alors des partis sont mortels on
le sait est midi justement est-ce qu'il
sert encore à quelque chose juste est
juste une observation d'assurer la nuque
ce parce que ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on dit que la nuque va mourir et à
chaque fois finalement elle est toujours
là et simplement sur les sujets ce que
vous disiez le fond moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il se passe quand même à
l'assemblée même si ça n'aboutit pas des
oppositions de projet de société
justement on commence par parler du fond
alors qu'on avait complètement oublié
auparavant on propose des projets de
société qui sont très opposées qui sont
sur des valeurs économiques sociales
industrielles financières qui sont très
différentes ça se discute ça m'a pas
beaucoup plus loin sur les projets de
loi mais en tout cas il ya des
discussions
et je suis entièrement d'accord avec
vous on va vraiment quelque chose de qui
peut être ressemblent à des débats qu'on
a déjà vécu notamment dans les années 80
sur le plan économique est en tout cas
des débats qu'on entendait plus et on
les a à nouveau sur le pouvoir d'achat
par exemple on a entendu un débat entre
ceux à gauche qui miser tout sur les
salaires et puis d'autres au centre
droit qui était plus sur la question de
la prime bon bah là on a typiquement
quelque chose qui est on n'est pas
entendu depuis longtemps alors peut-être
que c'est pas nouveau pour ceux qui ont
déjà vécu ça il ya une dizaine trentaine
d'années mais mais on a aussi d'autres
débats qui sont sur la posture politique
où l'homme la stratégie politique et le
comportement politique et ça c'est aussi
quelque chose de très intéressant parce
qu'on a d'un côté des gens qui sont à
droite ou à gauche dans une forme de
radicalité en dix ans pour changer les
choses il faut agir vigoureusement
quitter ce qui est des perdants et des
gens qui en souffrent immédiatement les
riches quand on est de gauche par
exemple et et puis en face cinq ans
peut-être pas le camp de la raison n'est
en tout cas c'est les réformistes qui
pense que les choses vont pouvoir
s'améliorer
par voilà la négociation le compromis
non je ne t'avais pas davantage mais ce
ce débat politique ce débat sur les
modalités de l'action politique eh ben
on n'est pas entendu aussi clairement
pendant pendant des années
rené et c'est quand même très
intéressant parce que les questions
posées sont absolument essentielles
les petites phrases les petites phrases
de l'année quand même je vous avais
demandé peut-être d'y penser je vous en
propose quatre vous allez me dire
laquelle vous parle de plus le peuple
français
n'a pas prolongé le mandat qui s'achève
commencé le 14 mai 2017 ce peuple
nouveau différent d'il ya cinq ans a
confié un président nouveau un mandat
nouveau
je suis venu ce soir vous dire une chose
je demande aux français de m'élire
premier ministre
je leur demande pour mes lire premier
ministre délire une majorité de députés
insoumis nous incarnerons une opposition
ferme c'est à dire sans connivence mais
une opposition responsable
c'est à dire respectueuse des
institutions est toujours constructif
depuis des mois je sillonne la france je
rencontre des français
deux craint plaisante celle du grand des
classements avec l'appauvrissement des
français le déclin de notre puissance et
l'effondrement de notre école est celle
du grand remplacement avec
l'islamisation de la france
l'immigration de masse
sécurité
bon alors je vous ai pas mis le bon vin
le bon fromage de caméras il appelle à
l'aide pécresse enfin bref j'aurais pu
en mettre beaucoup lâche laquelle vous
vous marquent le plus au ptr spotting
l'année où peut-être celle de jean luc
mélenchon je demande aux français mais
leur premier ministre parce que pour moi
c'est la quintessence de la politique
c'est la force des mots grâce à cette
formule grâce à ces mots il a en
quelques jours et à force de répétition
dans les médias parfois vociférante avec
ses troupes certes mais néanmoins il a
réussi à renverser effectivement c'est
de la stratégie politique extraordinaire
c'est la stratégie politique d'une force
incroyable il a réussi à renverser
effectivement en partie dans l'opinion
publique le résultat d'une élection de
faire en sorte que les satisfaits le
troisième tour ses balles volent et
égrener vaut donc pour moi non mais oui
mais c'est la sémantique cc c'est par
ces mots là qu'il réussit ce coup là
donc et ça prouve aussi que la politique
reste ça reste la puissance et la force
des mots et de la rhétorique c'est l'art
du verbe et ce vers de là à changer les
choses c'est pas que ça a été
performatif parce que la poésie premier
ministre mais mais parler par par son
expression il a changé et une destinée
politique parce qu'on s'attendait pas du
tout à ça et où toutes les autres phases
convient d'entendre on n'a pas une seule
qui a dont l'impression reste c'est à
dire que emmanuel macron quand il dit
voilà c'est un nouveau mandat un nouveau
président ben on a déjà oublié
ça va ça vient vous auriez choisi les
mêmes oui incontestablement c'est celle
qui a été la plus efficace dans les
effets c'est là où on voit que la parole
peut être performative pour le coup les
autres je suis un président nouveau avec
un bond à nouveau je peux qu'en france
on se souvient déjà plus après sur le
fond la stratégie mais ça n'est pas la
manière dont ces formules et qui est
plus efficace est probablement celle de
marine le pen qui qu'elle évoquait dans
la phrase que vous avez diffusé sur le
sa volonté de respectabilisation mais
les hans a très largement aidé
d'ailleurs par jean luc mélenchon en
quelque sorte vous pourrez dire qu'eric
zemmour à dédiaboliser jean luc
mélenchon l'a notabilisé avant de
conclure ce débat va faire un petit
aperçu sur la saison prochaine
une personnalité à suivre une révélation
qui va compter pour vous nicolas précède
il y en a pas mal en fait alors j'en
cite mais oui parce qu'on a un personnel
politique à peut renouveler donc j'en
citerai de sandrine rousseau pour les
écologistes parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle qu'elle parle dans l' écoute
andy mackay ce qu'elle va bien pouvoir
dire cette fois ci donc voilà ça fait
partie du talent politique quoi qu'on
pense de de ces options et puis
peut-être aussi valérie rabault à gauche
parce que là on les bouquets tout à
l'heure la nuque quel sera son avenir
quel pourrait être le leur au loup le
positionnement d'une valérie rabault ça
c'est quelque chose qui peut être
intéressant jean sébastien ferjou si
vous deviez faire un pari entre
l'explosion de la gauche où l'union des
droites
vous feriez quoi comme paris pour
l'année prochaine je tôt l'explosion de
la prochaine
réunion des droites et varela sur vous
avez une quelqu'un à suivre c'est pas
une révélation mais moi quelqu'un que je
trouve particulièrement intéressant est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui est une journée
importante avec les décisions de la
banque centrale européenne sur les taux
c'est christine lagarde parce qu'on ne
mesure pas ce que la france doit à
christine lagarde elle nous a protégés
des pressions allemandes pour augmenter
les taux d'intérêt des allemands n'ont
pas du tout la même vision de la
politique monétaire que nous on a
beaucoup de débat en france sur le
pouvoir d'achat machin ça on sait faire
des chèques mais on ne se pose pas la
question de comment on a gagné l'argent
avant il se trouve quand même que nous
faisons partie d'une zone monétaire
commune et que les fondamentaux de notre
croissance de notre richesse de notre
prospérité se joue beaucoup à francfort
et christine lagarde adossement de judas
très bien défendu les intérêts de la
france et a beaucoup plus d'impact que
bruno le maire ou n'importe quel autre
ministre l'économie et des finances en
aura jamais emilie est une révélation à
suivre moi je pense qu'il ya gabriella
talent qui a bien manié son chemin tu
pars parole maintenant ministre des
comptes publics un jeune qui a vraiment
le verbe qui a la politique est nuancée
qui a probablement qu'à finir motion
exceptions seraient des comptes publics
au budget exactement savaria ou magic
avait bien étudié le cas est même à
craindre est ce que vous pouvez dire
vous pouvez nous dire dissolution ou pas
de dissolution dans la prochaine saison
je ne sais rien je ne suis que jonas
politique on ne fait que se tromper en
permanence donc je pense
qu'effectivement oui
si les blocs albums en même temps on
voit que lors de l'examen des premières
des premiers textes on voit que les
négociations semblent semblent aboutir
avec les républicains on en parlait à
l'instant si elles aboutissent et qui a
pas de blocage complet sur le passage
des réformes sur le vote des réformes je
pense que la dissolution d'un n'arriva
pas dans les semaines ou dans les mois
qui viennent mais néanmoins si le
blocage se fait entre effectivement la
nuque d'un côté le rassemblement
national de l'autre il n'aura d'autre
choix que de que de co2 ou dhr pour les
révélations
ont soufflé à suivre et dizaine de
bornes parce que je pense que c'était
une nomination énorme et qui était assez
controversé étaient tous ces petits
quand elle a été nommée et je trouve
pour l'observer depuis quelques les
premières semaines effectivement de sa
nomination sauf qu'on voit qu'elle prend
goût à l'exercice que le discours de
politique générale on voit qu'elle prend
goût effectivement à effective à cette
joute verbale que l'hémicycle donc ça je
trouve ça assez intéressant je pensais
en auberge et aussi parce qu'une femme
aussi jeune c'était pas la candidate de
l'île
mais n'ont pas vu les femmes au perchoir
voilà des
parlementaires de la majorité s'étaient
pas la candidat de l'elysée elle va
jouer un rôle essentiel effectivement
dans les négociations ont dit que la
politique va se faire désormais au
parlement mais elle aura un rôle de
premier plan et de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier je pensais à jordan bardella
qui a un parcours que je trouve sans
faute qui aujourd'hui est à la tête du
second parti de france qui va sans doute
13h26 ouais 26 juin donc très jeune
parcours sans faute il ne s'est pas mise
en danger il va sans doute hérité du
second parti de france à la rentrée eh
bien merci à tous c'est la fin de ce
premier débat